der intellekt ist eine linie emotion ist
raum da sagt der weltberühmte schweizer
architekt peter zum turm ist eine
bauwerk geschaffen sinnliche atmosphäre
seine architektur ist luft geräusche
farben materialien und formen
peter zum tor selbst gilt als äußerst
präzise streng bisweilen sogar als stur
und eigensinnig braucht es das damit
gute architektur entstehen kann
was ist sein geheimnis herz unter
herzlich willkommen was ist schönheit
für sie
das sind kostbare augenblicke den
schnell vorbei
man denkt zurück und auch das war schön
und das nicht unbedingt dort formen
geburt und das kann landschaften die
landschaft zahlen gestern abend in
kunsthallen garten keys die bäume die
wärme das war schön
wir könnten wir haben ganz verschiedene
schönhals haben
manchmal ist sogar architektur schon und
was bewegt können sie das den bestimmen
benehmen
was mich bewegt in der arbeit oder im
leben ja vielleicht nicht das verteilt
werden
zu recht das ist nicht zurück zu wenden
was ich arbeite sehr gerne also ich war
auch schon so die frage gestellt und ich
jetzt das aufgeben soll
in meinem alter mit der andere aufgaben
gegeben
dabei scheint sie mir zugehört erlebe
des glücklichseins bei der arbeit zum
beispiel baden fragen dass sie können
das vermutlich die freude des beginns
wenn man sagt so jetzt beginnt etwas
dazwischen die idee da und plötzlich
wird zwischen irgend wollen unterwegs
damit hat jetzt funktioniert selbst habe
ich glaube dass diese fragen können
wovon träumen sie aber das wollte ist am
schluss des gesprächs ist das noch nicht
gemacht aber ich glaube ich möchte ein
bisschen darauf hin kommen diese die
situation dem intellekt dem geistigen
und der emotion und dass die emotionen
etwas ist was eben wie sie es schon
eingangs in verschieden aber etwas
flüchtiges ist und nie wenn man
architektur liest oder selber macht und
kreiert wie dieses emotionale moment wie
wichtige bedeutungsvolles das ist der
nationale empfinden das genaue
hinschauen
das beobachten das steht für mich im
zentrum
es gibt dinge in der architektur mit dem
ich berührende tolle mikrocontroller und
die berührt mich nicht im hirn sondern
möglich machen das ist der seele oder
märz oder im ganzen körper und nachher
frage ich mich was macht denn da so und
das ist für mich die bessere methode um
irgendeine in die tiefe zu kommen weil
mein emotion und das bei aller menschen
so das zeichnet uns aus dass wir ende
sind uns zwar viel in uns tragen dass
wir gespeichert haben
von dem wir vermutlich nicht wissen dass
wir das alles in uns tragen und das ist
mein material das versuche ich hab zu
rufen so arbeite ich auch mit früher mit
den studenten heute mit meinen
mitarbeiterinnen mit popal eine junge
architekt wie sie sich annähern an einen
ort die bedeutungsvoll ist der raum der
hut sein die topographie das klima der
ort ist wichtig dass jetzt mal das motto
es gibt leute die sagen wenn sie daneben
und übernachten
und das hat eigentlich gar nichts mit
dem zu tun ich habe eigentlich
ich habe früher hätte ich bin
unglaublich neugierig ich irgendwohin
und ich lebe dann das zuschauen bevor
ich das buch drüber gelesen habe wieder
das gleiche thema und beginne dann
vielleicht ein bisschen zu spüren was in
der landschaft im ort gespeichertes das
geschichte und ich bin vielleicht nicht
der ungeschickte rinn das dann zu sehen
und zu sehen und der gehalt ob kaffee
und sein und dann spüre ich vielleicht
8000 ja oder doch mehr das kann jeder
mensch ob das ist meine faszination d
sich so hin und dann stellen sich wird
und gleichzeitig weist sie schon was ich
da machen müsste und schon stehen sich
die bilder ein
und das ist natürlich das schöne das ist
dann wenn nicht tage umher gehe mich
häufiger den blick abwenden
abflüsse stark das hilft das ist
wunderbar dann stellt sich bilder ein
und ich kann die bilder sofort weil die
sind halt wirklich keine gedanken bilde
durch ruhm und kam die schon autoren
stelle in meinem kopf ausprobieren und
plötzlich springt der funke oder so sie
haben ihren ihren stift in der hand als
er dann ist das stift also auf diesen
wünschelruten gängen auch nicht dabei
sind und die notieren zeichnenden oder
ist diese ablagerung das ist der alles
das ist alles im kopf so dass heißt
entwerfen für mich ist gedanken und
gefühle haben wir ein ehrlicher prozess
hinter und verstehen dinge
zusammenbringen das sich leicht mit dem
vom bauherrn sagen das hätte sie gerne
was brauchen sie und dann und ich sammle
dann alle diese informationen und
speicher dieser wie dass ich das alles
mal was sie wollen und lassen dass ich
sage den leuten dann lasst mich aber
auch über das programm doch diskutieren
vielleicht wollte er es nicht alles was
ihr wollt wir können zusammen und dann
schauen
mit diesem hintergrundwissen gegen diese
sind unter besten geschwollen aber so
was die sinnliche erfahrung sforza ist
sehr emotional da fühle ich mich wohl
wie ein fisch im wasser
ich habe keine probleme da orte zu
verstehen ich liebe die antwort wie zu
sagen ob das muss ich noch anfügen
ich liebe die gespeicherte geschichte an
und in den ort das ist sie haben alle
sind schön schon schon auf den tisch
gelegt eigentlich eben diese emotionen
das speichern und sie werden ja immer
auch in verbindung gebracht mit dem
begriff der spiritualität das ist ein
spiritueller architekt sie haben auch
sakralbauten schon sehr früh gebaut
dieses abspeichern diese tradition als
der eigenen zeit hinaus gehen eines der
früheren beispiele ist san benedetto und
haben wir ein paar bewegte bilder dass
man sich das auch
anschauen kann hier hoffentlich so und
die frage bildet sich ganz genau das ist
einer der schönsten welche gibt es sonst
es gibt sie sehen hier das innere der
kirche also der kapelle sehen wir die
eigentlich ungewöhnliche formen an
diesem ort für eine für ein sakralbau
sowieso das berührt mich sehr es hat
also ich das zum ersten mal hört da wir
die weniger meisten frauen haben dies
also überhaupt ob ich überhaupt
donnerstag alle tat jede zweite woche
doch hingehen und aber auch singen mit
diesem brüchigen schönen normalen
stimmen das ist in diesem raum
das ist ein geschenk jetzt möchte ich
sie ein bisschen fragen wir feiern
demnächst auch schon in diesem jahr 500
jahre reformation und immer wieder wenn
man sich mit der reformation beschäftigt
die frage des kirchenraums des sakralen
raumes und was ihre formation mit diesen
katholischen gebäuden meist gemacht hat
wie werden sie das beschreiben was ist
der wechsel der radikale wechsel der
katholischen raum hat eine so wichtig
überall immer wieder als katholische
junge damals und auch jetzt auch erlebt
habe ist natürlich so voller emotionen
voller emotionalen gerümpel und so
weiter und tritt und ich lebe das ich
bin so aufgewachsen dass sieht man aber
jetzt nicht unbedingt reduzierte klare
reine nicht alles was ich lebe muss ich
in der architektur machen meisten dinge
die in der architektur geschehen
die habe nicht direkt mit den gebäuden
unternehmen den räumen zu tun aber es
freut mich wenn ich das ermögliche
deswegen sage ich auch wenn ich den
gesang die gebete oder frauen immer wie
das klingt das ist so mein ding also
aber der katholische kirchen raum
wenn ich zurückdenke gehört haben war
das eine der ersten auf die tektur
erfahrungen
ich bin in einem von meinem vater
geplanten einfamilienhaus von 1950 er
aufgewachsen da war alles irgendwie
billig also etwa anständig aber die
räume waren drei und die türen jackpot
das war heute keine architektonische
qualität und ich mich zurückgehalten sie
das damals schon gespielt
nein nein nichts von alle dem das ist
alles ich da zurückgeschaut zurück und
sage doch hinter geraten die kapelle in
mariastein das war doch was hat die
stufen hinunter zu gehen raten kapelle
was ich hab es die kennen und dann oben
aber zuerst informiert zu werden auf
diesem platz nachdem wir in der prozesse
halbe stunde querfeld dahinter fahrende
voraus und so weiter daher ärgert sind
jedes jahr einmal ganz auf diesen platz
zu kommen und dann die diese barocke
fassade steht da steht dann hinein in
diesen barocken rahm mit dem gemalten
himmel der mir einfach dass himmel
vorkam auch heute nicht so ist eine
gemalte geschichte aber so hat dieses
herrschaftliche entschloss
und auch die männliche sie sind vorne
hinter geld bereicherung nicht rein darf
und dann aber die gnadenkapelle und die
felsen treppe und dann das schönste das
war schön und das schönste die männliche
der männergesangverein kuh oder also der
beleg ich aber zurück auf architektur
erlebnisse ob ich hatte sich offenbar
sind wir geblieben
dieses das bewegen im raum und die
verschiedenen intensitäten sie ist sich
etwas wie das sogar noch zu sprechen
kommen werden und dass eine art von
leitmotiv aber vielleicht jetzt noch
einmal um diese art von von spiritueller
dimension ein bisschen auszulösen was
das für sie bedeutete dann wie sie mit
diesem begriff umgehen achten oder
vielleicht mit mit dem etikett ja ich
arbeite dich zu ich will nicht
spirituell sein das hätte ich nie im
sinn
und ich arbeite auch nicht nach entlang
von begriffen also kann ich nicht will
ich nicht aber ich liebe gut gestimmte
reim ich bin ich bin ein absolut report
von räumen und ich versuche meine räume
so zu machen dass sie eine schöne
stimmigen atmosphäre haben und zwar
nicht dass das pilz und der körper haft
präsent mit den materialien so und das
ist meine leidenschaft und vielleicht
bin ich auch nicht schlecht
und das ist aber schon mit meinem 35
leuten dienten tag daran zu arbeiten 100
und von modellen und das dann dass eine
ausstrahlung hat die andere menschen
wahrnehmen und der spirituell oder wie
auch immer sagen
das schon gemacht aber ich sie wirklich
beginne ja nicht dort aber was ich weiß
ist spannend finde jetzt also ich habe
ein bisschen den verdacht gehabt sowie
ist das absolute gehör gibt gibt es
vielleicht auch das absolute baum
empfinden und jetzt zu sagen ist dass
ein talent das ihnen mitgegeben wurde
also sozusagen spüre spielräume und ich
spüre auch den raum den es braucht also
architektonisch den hladins macht um
einen raum zu fassen und einer lehre
form zu geben dass du eine faszinierende
aufgabe für mich der kern der
architektonischen architektur des baus
das sind das erfinden von räumen von
räumen die gut passen müssen
zu ihrem gebracht aber das und das ist
doch eine geheimnisvolle auch bei das
war das team zudem zu dem ich finde das
glas und wie wunderbar wenn ich dieses
los habe mir da kein schaden was wir da
alles glitzern sehen dass die schiene
dieser korb und sonst das geht überhaupt
nicht zu diesem glas ist also weiter
sting beispiel sondern nein ich jetzt
gerade
also arbeite ich also ich habe ein
gefühl untersagt und danach noch mehr
von dem also schlecht oder geld und das
tut er zudem genau und so weiter
das gepaart mit auch gedacht
dass die arbeit und dann aber diese das
richtige richtige quantität so viel von
dem so viel von tape das open das unter
und das dann ins licht zu setzen
was wir jetzt gut erleben oder in den
schatten was die zuschauer ist ein was
ich aber glaube da ist ebenso wichtig
was ist wo und da gibt es keine mehr
gibt schönen dinge die aus der tiefe
strahlen durch den sektor aber es hätte
es auch bedeuten dass das spontan jeden
oder irgendetwas einrahmen etwas
auslösen sollte also das nicht
intelligent ist was keinen für
verbraucher einen film gesagt schade
hier jahren hat sich das gedacht sondern
diese art von unmittelbarkeit
das kind ist für mich das schönste an
dieser kunst baukunst da wo sie diese
präsenz erzeugt die nahe an der natur
empfindung ist die auf enter präsenz
beginnt und dann und so weiter aber die
beginnende wurzelt dort und das find ich
wunderschöne architektur tus wird dass
da auch haben und wer aber auch wir
brauchen alle es kommt dann vielleicht
noch etwas
also wenn ich das unmittelbar ich komme
in einem raum der von ihnen gestaltet
ist ich spüre etwas und ich spüre aber
immer auch seine art von von bedürfnis
fast so nach kontemplation also nach
verlängerung eines spontanen erlebnis
ist oder also im nachsetzen lasten eines
raumes und ja auch hier arbeitsprozess
also dass sie sind ja nicht ein sehr
schneller architekt oder sondern dass
diese art von setzen lassen ausprobieren
auszahlt die perfektion entwickeln
erarbeiten
dass das doch längere lange momente
langsame momente vielleicht können also
ich denke von mir selbst ziemlich
schnell also im denken der schüler habe
das machen ist natürlich etwas anderes
machen häuser 1000 materialien
zusammensetzen tausend dinge verstehen
die man vorher nicht verstanden hat und
da bleibt hier ist es her dass man man
müsste eine gute architektur so
anschauen wie eine sinfonie oder wie ein
bild an seine melodien sind sie sind
anlagen langsam aus dem turnier
schreiben oder oder mit dem picasso du
hast jetzt aber lange gehabt diesem bild
normalerweise baustahl stunden also was
ich in direkter lage ist ich bleib dir
dafür dass man auch in der architektur
einen künstlerischen weg inzwischen
prozesshaften weg gehen kann und dann
muss ich gehen um zu guten trifft daten
zu kommen das können sie wenn sie ein
buch schreiben oder eine ist das kennen
wir alle
wir müssen das wieder mal ruhen lassen
und schauen ob ein bisschen die ein
bisschen distanz dazu gewinnen und das
wirke der anzuschauen
stimmt es was ist uns weiter so dass da
ein normaler künstlerischer prozess
deklamieren ist für yahoo ich habe es
mehr nach ein bisschen meint das
verstehe ich sehr gut also dass das
natürlich eine eigene damit hat ein
großes gebäude zu bauen als ein bild zu
malen oder so aber auch etwas was mir
beim lesen ihrer texte aufgefallen ist
dass es so etwas gibt wie die suche nach
dem des sehens ohne denken also dass man
das den intellekt runterfährt und und so
sehe einfach einfach
[Musik]
stimmt ich denke gerne lese gerne
philosophen ist schließt auch gerne
gedichte
es ist ich bin bei das habe sie haben
schon recht dass er versucht doch mal
serie frage genau
also wieso wird das jetzt bei mir also
kontemplativ das war's ja was haben sie
dort aus zu steuern
ich kann sich halt kann es vielleicht
sogar den sprung wagen jetzt sagen also
wir haben auf unserer starken gerettet
und ein beispiel gesehen
jetzt könnten wir eigentlich
museumsbauten und sagen die art des
sehens macht also das sind räume für
sehen in den kirchen zum beispiel
bregenz also wenn wir in diese epoche
bleiben wir auch hier haben wir ein bild
das man sich das anschauen kann
und das ist eine ganz andere geschichte
also sagen wir denken und dass sie wenn
es in comic vom kirchenraum im sakralen
raum mit einer klaren aufladung einen
religiösen konnotierten einem programm
das das spirituell ist also von der
materie weg geht und das museum ist so
etwas wie die kirche des 20 21
jahrhunderts mit ja bei einem anderen
bewusstsein hintergrund also wir haben
dort ist das spirituelle außer ich liebe
gelassene räume gelassen hat ist für
mich ein großes thema und was ich immer
noch suchen wo es langsam besser werde
ist dazu auch noch heiterkeit
also wenn ich jetzt mal eine bauten
anzahl von beginnender spüren
pionierhaften spannung und jetzt und so
und wenn ich mein neues zuhause schade
dass jetzt dahin der gas zu stellen
denke ich jetzt komm ich langsam zu
gelassenheit und heiterkeit so aber
steckt immer ein kern das schön und ob
das schöne atmosphärische raum muss
immer da sein also den will ich das ist
interessant weil ihm das wäre jetzt die
anderen attribute und sagt jetzt haben
wir das spirituelle zum theoretiker mal
angeschaut ich könnte mir das dass die
stufen und eigensinnigen zumthors dieses
etikett was auch gibt was man immer
wieder hört und sie reden von heiterkeit
und gelassenheit geht das zusammen
ja das andere sind da war und das bin
jetzt weiß ich wie viel staat zu wahl
getragen habe gewisse dinge für
selbständig zu schenken sich aber das
heißt ja wie soll ich das leben der
einfachen otto ich gebaut habe und etwas
steht das sind die bauherren die das mit
mir gemacht haben wir sind freunde
geworden nichts von irgendwas hat
hingehen oder also man gibt es gibt da
gibt es die wirkliche begegnung mit dem
bauwerk aber das okay ich kann damit
leben
das ist ja wirklich eine zentrale
geschichte becken architekt und also
diese beziehung zum bauherrn und dass
das ist wirklich eine art von von
schicksalsgemeinschaft ist was es geht
nicht ohne einander
ihnen auch hier vielleicht wieder eine
ein klischee oder ein etikett aber man
bekommt ein bisschen eindruck dass sie
sich eigentlich ihre bauherren aussuchen
und nicht umgekehrt
es gibt beides gibt es heute dort werden
programme geschrieben vom spezialisten
häufig größer die gebäude um so ist das
büro mit irgendwelchen kompetenzen
fachwissen die schreiben dann aber haben
sie das mit 16 quadratmeter von 33 unter
x 3 und problem und weiter das wird
festgehalt und in einem programm das
gibt der architekt und der architekt
setzt um ok und architekt und sagt da
wird das geprüft vorgeschrieben sind das
57 73 und da ist noch nicht
vorgeschrieben das hat es nicht und so
weiter so ich bin kein umsätze ok also
wenn sie mit der bahn waren
dann müssen sich graphen gemeint haben
einen prozess an weg zu gehen wo wir
gemeinsam das nochmals anschauen was sie
wollen und am ende des prozesses
vielleicht sogar etwas besseres wollen
als sie am anfang gewalt hätten und so
weiter dank diesem prozess und das habe
ich einfach sorge macht da war ein ganz
normales hallenbad gefragt das habe ich
in bregenz war das so immer mit gutem
erfolg und in freundschaft in bregenz da
wollte man eine landesgalerie mit zwei
bisschen verstaubt und zwei besten
kunsthallen und das war auch toll
keystone von cologne köln und die kamen
schon zu mehr waren sie sagt wir sind
mit ihnen können wir die columbus ein
gutes beispiel dafür einen bischof
gebaut
wie war das also ja das war gut weil er
hat gesagt er hat zum tor sie sehen die
saat er mehr als widerpart hass und da
war ja für das konservative aber da er
warne abenteuer und open ich hab dann
gearbeitet mit den museumsleuten vor ort
das so toll und haben zwischen
rechenschaft geben
und da ich habe mir haben und verstand
es ist halt design begriff den ich ihnen
jetzt mal zu werke auch in dieser
beziehung kompromiss ich lerne oder das
heißt zu diesem prozess gehört wird dazu
dass mein gegenüber manchmal recht hat
und wer mich kennt der weiß wie ich
frage ich fragt die handwerker und wenn
nicht wir können zwei stunden lagen
dahinter vielleicht abschluss sage dann
also jetzt ellenberger findet sie das
jetzt gut was wir beschlossen haben
können sie dahinter stehen
finden sie das gut und zu mache ich da
und wenn der verein da fange ich wieder
von vorne ich brauche das fachwissen der
handwerker der ingenieure aber auch bei
einer auftraggeber und aber ich brauche
den ab dem persönlichen auftraggeber
nicht die baukommission denn sie wenn
die ich einfach ein gremium gegen
überhaupt das sagt ja zeit geld da ist
das programm achtung fertig los
das gerät nicht da kommt auch so fertig
sagte ich komm nicht das beste resultat
dabei heraus
das heißt ich muss eine busse am schluss
aber in einem persönlichen kontakt ein
gutes werk geschafft so liebig
da kommen gute resultate raus und da bin
ich nicht einzige oder da bitte ich
dereinst auch direkt er so arbeitet und
gibt doch ganz ganz viele architekten
die gerne so arbeiten würden und nicht
so arbeiten können
das verhältnis zum bauherrn das
verhältnis zu ihren eigenen zu ihrem
inneren professionellen umfeld also ihre
mitarbeiter student dann auch ihre
familie ist das ist das ebenso
anspruchsvollen also diese art von
gemeinsamen suchen und dann wissen sie
sind sie der kapitän fiel aus und
empfiehlt also wir sind zu wissen wie
eine familie
das soll jetzt sind das sind wir 35
leute und da sind viele glauben
mehrheitlich frauen mittlerweile
durchaus schön fände architekten
architektin den studenten der
administrative ebene die wunderbare
arbeit gut da ich sagte ihr müsst ihr
könnt nur bei mehr sein wenn ihr mir
helfen wollt meine häuser bauen
ich habe nicht die häuser die und allen
gefallen ich brauche dich deine häuser
zu mir wenn du wirst kannst du mir
helfen weil ich brauche hilfe
es geht nicht ohne hilfe ich und so ist
die stimmung die stimmung ist
konzentriert und schön weil die das auch
täglich erleben weil die können und
sagen gefällt mir nicht
und da müssen sich das nicht begründen
wenn jemand bei mir gefällt das nicht
da denke ich aha da stimmt was nicht
dass nämlich ernst
sie würden sie das nicht noch begründet
weil ich finde eine persönliche meinung
ist die persönliche meinung um zweiter
dass das gleiche was wir anfangs hat
noch zu den glauben in die evolution als
leitmotiv das
logo für mein auto da ja klar weil man
kann jetzt sagen also das ist ja auch
inhalten scheint wo sie arbeiten sowie
ein kleiner campus ist das leben wo
arbeiten weit herum sind alles in diesem
auch so ein bisschen diese
abgeschiedenheit und von den großen
achsen den metropolen ist ist diese
konzentration was mich dann wo
unternehmen würde weil der der große
architektur journalist gantenbein hat
nachgerechnet also die lehre monografie
von 2004 sechs kilo schwer und klavier
43 projekte sind trainer hat so ein
hochgerechnet auf alle projekt auch die
geburt drin sind und hat gesagt
herausgefunden also 52 art und haben sie
realisiert
2004 17 sind die noch in werten gewesen
und 70 sind nur als plan
da das ist natürlich bei diesen 70 ist
es ja auch scheitern oder aber eben
nicht ein erfolg wie geht man damit um
das ist manchmal sehr schwer
oder es hat mich immer schwer wenn man
das sind kind dort beginnt zu wachsen
plötzlich werden die geknickte dagegen
kein wasser wie kann sowas
das ist immer schwer und jetzt deswegen
schauen mit wem ich mich verbinden wir
sorgfältig und sorgfältiger nach ihnen
ja und da auch noch andere sicht haben
in gewissen situationen zur genau das
möchte ich da
machen so muss mir natürlich dann und
von ferne betrachten der arroganz
einbringen könnte
dass ich für berühmte leute sagt nein da
möchte ich nicht machen aber ich schütze
mich ich will nicht in diese situation
kommen nur ich glaub plötzlich
irgendetwas beginne zu denken und unter
der dusche davon träume und dann das
sagt ja schon gut aber es macht macht
was ihr habt jetzt mehr passiert immer
wieder also da versuche ich mich zu
schützen
in der auswahl neuer partner also haben
sie angst vor absagen oder vor ich habe
angst der fotos wenn etwas unterwegs ist
das anders
geknickt wird oder das habe ich
natürlich immer wer lebt da das tut weh
und häufig sind die motive schlecht
begreifen wenn einer sagt irgendetwas ab
weil er jetzt plötzlich einen target
absolventen hatten daher die mit gesagt
ja wie das weiter machst du das schaffst
du das wird 'n ihren tieren
ich denke das war falsch verarbeitet das
muss ich akzeptieren dass solche dick
und in diesen in diesen prozessen drehen
also die angst vor dem gehabt vor dem
dass das dass das kind nicht auf die
welt kommt also diese diesen aspekt aber
auch wo wir haben sie selber fehler
gemacht dass wenn sie sagen diesen
strengen prozess weiter radikal sein
wenn wir da
ist es nicht gut zurückgehen noch einmal
und dann wird's ein strenger prozess von
äußeren faktoren gekappt die sagen ja
habe ich habe ich doch fehler gemacht ja
und werfe ich ein hotel das sind auch
heute noch glücklich wettersystem nur
darin dass der wüste dieses der heute
noch sind die wie viele leute ganz so
schaut dass du das nicht darum glaubt
dass dort also und da war eben dieser
halstücher gerade das wo der
herzspezialist haben gesagt so geht das
nicht wird nie rentieren
da kann ich mich jetzt fragen was ich
beantworte jetzt die frage zum ersten
mal habe ich dort fehler gemacht hätte
ich angst nur 44 220 planen sondern
damit auch alles billiger wäre hätte ich
auch stadt diese geschwungenen ihm
einige wunderbare vorgespannte form die
da wie eine große sehr groß das blatt in
der wüste liegt hätte ich da komplett in
eller und und schon wenn ich das erzähle
merklich nein also fehler war dass
keiner das ich bin hatte ich dass ich
das ist meine antwort auf diese
fragestellung so würde ich das tun
und da müsste ich jetzt bald abstimmung
aber kommt da dann wieder diese
gelassenheit in heiterkeit ein bisschen
insel ufenau nicht bauen darf
nicht zur gute dinge gesehen ist das
zunächst kommt mir manchmal vor ist das
wie ein bisschen gift des schmerzes
eingelagert in meinem körper das ich
daraus auf beugen muss und das dauert
kürzung wird
jetzt haben wir ein bisschen von
scheidung gesprochen haben sie den
pritzker-preis geworden also es ist die
größte auszeichnung überhaupt in ihrem
fachgebiet was hat es mit ihnen
angestellt
da kommt doch nicht wirklich wir sind
die kirche oder das ist schon vor der
haustür hört es bereits damals war zu
hause sind wir immer noch die alten
immer noch gleich miteinander und meine
kinder die machen auch mal abfällige
bemerkungen über was ich das auto da ist
alles klar so besonders und das ja nicht
sein preis aber samt hat ist ein beitrag
zur gelassenheit also ich habe jetzt das
gefühl ich muss nicht so kämpfen ich bin
aufgewachsen aus so aus kämpfer ich
musste für fehlers kämpfen und das hat
mir jetzt auch andere dinge haben mir
geholfen die sogar karsai ich wusste da
sehen wir dass das falsch ist
ich war aber kein heute manchmal auch
aber das hat zum gelassenheit
beigetragen und es gibt auch leute die
sehen nämlich dafür dass ist das schön
aber das ist nicht wirklich zentral
zentrale
da ist das sei ein bisschen kitschig da
war war wieder mal in köln vor zwei
jahren kaum niedriger die kinder gern
beim schloss noch zementiert und ich
wollte nur noch sagen
immer wenn es mir schlecht geht kommt
nicht darin dieses mal selbst das wurde
und ich wieder weg gegangen als er durch
besseres bett gereist ich habe mal
jemand anders hat ihn mal gesagt er
tennislehrer und offensichtlich als sie
sollten weniger denken beim tennisspiel
ja ich das immer noch also das weiß auch
er tennis spielen ein bisschen spät an
schlecht gespielt aber ähnliche dinge
dort ist die frage der konzentration
aber diese konzentration als ganzes ist
eine gelassene konzentration also die
arbeitsweise wenn ich das wenn ich mir
das anschaue dann habe ich sehe ich das
kann nicht immer wie besser dinge
beginnen und dann die stehen da modell
und dann lebe ich mit einem tag und
durch das nächste dach gut in der
reihenfolge dass ich nicht die falschen
dinge am anfang schon rein und so weiter
die dinge so wie fast entstehen lassen
wie schriftsteller manchmal sagen das
buch schreibt sich selbst oder solche
dinge aber so und dort ganz sorgfältig
mit diesem prozessor umzugehen sagt ein
dichter weg mit dem zeugt ein echter
dicht noch nicht noch nicht jetzt nur
dass diese konzentration
das teilt jetzt natürlich sehr auch das
sind klösterlich aber ich meine aber sie
sind ja ein großes büro 35 mitarbeiter
sie haben jetzt den wettbewerb für die
herren gewonnen indem teile an export
ist ein großes projekt in los angeles 1
600 millionen projekt das das land muss
ja also das heißt es sind ja große
tanker und also diese die
falkenstein konzentration und
beschaulichkeit fast wie man sie sich
vorstellt was ging ich habe gehört man
trägt bei ihnen filzpantoffeln wenn man
arbeitet wie diese welt sind die große
und die kleine in der konzentration noch
platz haben wie schaffen sie das
das skript sie müssen wir kommen das ist
ein falsches bild das ist ne da läuft
musik und so weiter und die
filzpantoffeln sind einfach dabei dass
die bo zwar hat zu tun wenn der rat von
den straßen im rhein oder ich habe das
in denen die ab und gefällt mir
das hat nichts mit kloster zu tun also
systeme anträge die sehr an manchmal
dichte weil es dort kaum mehr und die
leute zusammen um irgendwas anschauen so
dass er hat auch was vielleicht
konzentration und vielleicht ist das
letztlich war es eine bauhütte so war es
ist eine art meisterklasse oder und die
war sich ob sie das der staat aber es
ist ja je mehr ich dort bin ob mit den
leuten arbeiten um so mehr strahlen die
ist natürlich zwar jetzt kommt er hat
bei uns wird schwierig im gegenteil die
für alle verzichten das wir dann weiter
kommen und gemeinsam da hatte ich komm
nicht sagen usw
und da das große konzentration und
anspannung und aber auch gelassenheit
und ich glaube dass ich ein bisschen
gelernt so zu sagen wenn ich danach zum
es ist sehr schön wie sie das erteilen
diesen also was tagesablauf wo die
architektur mit der benutzung der
architektur verschmilzt dass man das
nicht auseinandersetzen kann und eines
der paradebeispiele beispiele die die
viele menschen kennen ist walz
therme in vals wo man spürt die
materialien des ht das weich- und wie
die menschen und hier haben mir auch
bewegte bilder dass man sieht wie man im
wasser drin
teil dieser architektur wird und diesen
raum zu füllen beginnt mit sich selbst
als eine art von klangkörpern und auf
dem monitor sehen dann ist das ja ein
paar zum entdecken das hält das ist der
architektonische thema führen oder
lassen also loslassen lassen und in den
häusern wieder diesen häusern sind wir
eben geführt gang sagte tage da da spürt
man dass ich versuche die wahl hat
zwischen verführen und führen
also ich sollte mich nicht verirren aber
es ist schön das zu machen wo man auch
entdecken kann
das mache ich eigentlich immer wieder
wenn ich bin ganz passt ich möchte noch
auf ihre anfänge zu sprechen kommen also
die materialität das ist ein wichtiger
punkt haben es auch angesprochen als sie
gehen zudem arbeit anfangen kann man das
mit olic und so sich selbst gelernter
scheint das wort anfang ihrer karriere
diese fans etwas über diesen anfang
sagen das ist nichts am anfang die hand
das material also sie geschrieben haben
vor allem mit dem glas und dem tisch wie
hat sie das natürlich geprägt
wenn ich zurückschaue hat dass alles
seine richtigkeit doch sobald man das
meiste was geschehen ist wollte ich
glaube ich bin ein schreiner werden
nein das war eine verpflichtung
gegenüber meinem vater selbst so und die
schreinerei zu nehmen da hat er mich
mehr oder weniger gezwungen das zu tun
und die schreinerei ja so eine
schreinerlehre zu machen das ist eine
der relativ harte geschichte wird sie
das nicht kennen oder der schneider sie
sich gefühlvoll mit dem holz unterwegs
noch eine schöne rundungen und so weiter
zu diesen halten spanplatten notfall und
bekannten werden angelangt und und war
dass das ganze eine unromantisch sehr
hart
also das ist keine romantik wenn ich
zurückschaue muss ich sagen das war
schon immer noch in einer
handwerkerfamilie aufzuwachsen wo
werkzeuge umlagen als ich jung war und
ich konnte mir alles machen was ich
wollte nicht da war nicht viel geld aber
ich habe dann alles selber gemacht da
war die werkbank und der haube bank und
die material und sklavisch hat mich
geprägt und dann die schreinerei gibt
einen natürlich sehe ich natürlich aus
exotik müsste jetzt dieses bein nicht
sein und diesem tisch oder das hätte
auch die hälfte gereicht und so weiter
das lernt man da und die statik des
hauses ist die statik des tisches sitzt
also einfach gesagt wenn sie ein haus
werner gebäude werden als wären sie
identität oder gar nicht ich bin ich
glaube ich sagt ich kann kein gebäude
soll ich bin zu egoistisch das ist ein
gebäude hat was denen das sah das und
das ist nicht das wenn sie mich fragen
würde ich wäre da wart ihr wären löwe
oder keine ahnung ob sowas und das
gebäude ist zudem könnte ist lustig weil
man sich ja immer vor danach ebenso sagt
dass sie dass sie ihre gebäude auch wie
fast persönlichkeit nach beschreiben und
erklären oder definieren oder sind wie
bekannt wonach in diesem segment hier
und da ist so ablegen
das merkt man auch wie sie über sie
schreiben und sagen ich gehe auch auf
kleine von nicht realisierten renken
wieder zurück wie werden mann ein
familienalbum anschlag als tante frieda
noch gewesen und jetzt ist nicht diese
die sind diesen aspekt da würde mich
natürlich interessieren jetzt zum
schluss hin eigentlich die die große
frage was was bleibt denn von von
jemanden also vielleicht mit einer
eingangsfrage sind sie eigentlich ein
moderner architektur weiß ich natürlich
nicht gesagt das wird mich an hüther
diese frage aber ich lebe jetzt folglich
gehöre ich zu dieser zeit und dann damit
für mich diese politik was ich ihnen
dann gerne sorge ist dass wir nicht
zurückschauen was ich gemacht habe dass
ich mit meinem gebäuden immer versuche
emotionen für die geschichte zu wecken
also die gebäude sollten das ist immer
wieder
simulieren die geschichte des ortes zu
lesen
das ist in köln soll mit dieser
unglaublichen zeitmaschine und das war
von anfang an so und ich hätte eine
freude wenn meine gebäudeteil des ortes
sind und etwas davon wissen dass dann
schon vor 500 und 1000 jahren menschen
waren und dinge warum also das würde mir
eine atmosphäre
ich werde gerne auf den 18 pavillons an
der expo in hannover zu sprechen kommen
das ist ja auf einem messegelände
gewesen mit mit relativ freien den
architektonischen nach waffen und sie
haben dort so etwas nie leben erzeugt
aus sich selbst heraus in der
abstraktion
also da sollte wohl ob sie das gesehen
haben sie das beschauliche leben
überhaupt
das war nicht die aufgabe die aufgabe
dort war in diesem getümmel dass ich
nicht liebe ehrlich gesagt diese eine
insel zu machen der kultur des
gesamtkunstwerks auch die sorgen der
schweizer hier zeigen wir wollen einfach
gute gastgeber sein und schreiben es
nicht darum was wir alles können das
merkt man dann direkt in den keeper aber
als sie dann wie wir musik machen wie
wie direktor machen dass wir etwas
könnte schreiben jetzt nicht auf oder so
machen und wird dass man meine super
aber das mache ich eben auch gerne
solche dinge ich mach jetzt im kunsthaus
bregenz diesen herbst was ähnliches wie
da war es in hannover und der pavillon
in den seitenteilen lg für das styling
in london war es dazu du hast dazu ja im
süden nepals als porto einer offenen
architektur der hors concours sus war
also wissen sie ich das ist das andere
das ist die geschichte des ortes die ort
ein geschriebene geschichte in
geschichten das was ich mich mehr
interessiert dass die geschichte auf
papier die und den universitäten von
papier papier gelehrt wird auch kommt
mir jetzt nicht mein ding ist die
präsenz sind die präsenten dinge und das
andere sind die gärten also die artisten
rückwirkend dass sich ja immer gerne
gemacht just atelier hat er einen garten
die kirche tabelle steht in der
landschaft fotos die wiesen und die kühe
bis an die fassade kommen können wir das
unter und da war dieser serpent 1
es wird ist ein paar aber noch das
mittel steigerung wie ein
vergrößerungsglas und das hat auch dann
funktioniert das ich da hingehe und dann
die pflanzen nochmals in einer neuen
intimität erleben weil zunächst würde ja
habe ich auch gehört das ist das für
eine birne weiche idee in einem park
eine garten zu machen aber gut
funktioniert so dass man gemein erd und
liebe das geheimnisvolle an diesem
objekt ich glaube der kleine körper in
hannover hatte mir für mich etwas sehr
ein einladendes ordnung ist genau das
was man ja von einem partner liebt und
das auf sich zurückgezogen
ein bisschen geheimnisvoll von von
london steckt ist ein bisschen wenn man
das überschneiden würde mit der arbeit
ist sie zusammen ja mit einem künstler
einem fotografen hans damals gemacht
haben
die früher auch zu sagen ich
ich delegiere wie ein in einen
künstlerischen freien blick also der
auch nicht in meinem dienste stärker und
san benedetto fotografiert von hand das
ergibt etwas ganz eigenes und das schöne
was mir so gefällt es ist neblig auf
diesem bild das ist ja das war mir
wichtig sind natürlich zuerst das thema
architektur ist architektur und die
kampagne hat bild und ich zeige und
bildern und normale fotos können nach
lügen das wissen wir alles rendering
flügen noch mehr das wissen mittlerweile
und trotzdem wollte ich in der
architektur galerie
das zeigen was ich mache und da war
dieser künstlerische blick das war für
mich die erlösung
ich weiß meine freilich war im
kunstmuseum geholt haben in vierow
gesehen sowie die fata nüssli kann die
damals recht sowie der fotografiert soll
müsste man das machen einen
künstlerischen blick zu haben
frei auf das ding da ist es nicht eine
reproduktion sondern ein eigenständiger
so ist das dort entstand war da hat
etwas gebracht aber wohl habe ich
natürlich mit zertifizierten und jetzt
leider sagen sie sich sehr schön zu
sprechen sie als architektin dieser
freiheit als künstler der auch
referenzen aus der kunst also tagen
immer wieder begriffe aus der
amerikanischen minimal art allen der dem
maria aragon alt sagt sagte barbara
roskow sind sind referenzen aber die
musik da müssen wir noch besprechen
klang was etwas was in ihrer form des
denkens fühlens spüren vermutlich die
das medium ist außerhalb
ja das ist etwas vom schwierigsten hat
einen eigenen klang und der hat sogar
eine eigene kleine welt still werden
würden würde ja das höre mir der durch
irgendwelche dinge erzeugt aber selbst
leer stehendes baumhaus oder einen
eigenen klang wenn man dann ruhig ist
und ich liebe es darüber zu machen die
den richtigen klang haben für ihren
gebrauch und da bin ich erst am anfang
eigentlich denke ich mehr da ich in
dieser akustischen phänomene zu
vertiefen und ich krieg einfach keinen
auftrag wird man eine konzertsaal zu
machen das ist schade vielleicht in los
angeles ist der laut kino das habe aber
diese räume haben einen klang das hat
mit wie sie wissen auch mit den
materialien zu tun
und du bist mir sehr wichtig und das
wichtigste im moment was zuerst muss ich
scharf weil wir leben in einer so
lärmigen umwelt und ich leide darunter
also wo ich auch hinkomme werde ich mit
musikkonzept musik gedrosselt und
bedröhnt und so weiter auf den straßen
ist das lärmen man hat mir gesagt mit
lauter gestank das schlimmste gewesen
und ich denke heute ist es da das heißt
ich muss zuerst lose häuser band immer
diesen lärm außen vor halten und dann
eine stille aufbauen und aus der stille
heraus wie der arbeiten ein sehr schönes
beispiel vielleicht jetzt so ist die
bruder klaus kapelle
davon haben wir vielleicht eine
impression wo man sich das vorstellen
kann
gut das ist auf einem fels da muss man
nicht
die flugzeuge ja also das war das was
was ist das spezielle an diesem an
diesem für sie wenn man sieht also ein
begriff der messe geblieben ist stampf
beton also dürfe beim hören von der bau-
und selber ein tagwerk in den schichten
gebaut
geschichten die zeit hatten haben sie cm
gestampft das heißt man den füßen einmal
mit zur grundhaltung wurde das geschafft
so dass auch rücksicht genommen auf den
arbeitseifer sollte daraus landwirt
selber mit seinem helfer daran selber
hat vermutlich etwas existenzielles das
will ich vielleicht macht das deutlich
begonnen habe ich habe es jetzt dazu
gemacht jetzt mal was richtig
zeitgenössisch moderne sich arbeite mit
sonnenenergie und weiter und weiter noch
zwei drei jahren war ich bei stein licht
schatten was auch regen vorjahr und das
ist natürlich dann diese kapelle und das
ist die das bauernehepaar leute meines
alters das sind diesen weg mit mir
mitgegangen sie wollten ein bildstöcken
amberger und für den bruder klaus und
auch die kapelle fertiger hat da war mir
dann gesagt man hat mir ein kurzes leben
branche zeit und jetzt bin ich so alt
das mache ich jetzt für den herrgott und
der bruder klaus ist mein lieblings
heiliger
da hab ich ja da auch bei lieblingsteile
geweihter mutter deswegen sind wir ja da
und er hat dann mehr aber auch außerhalb
dieser kapelle so essenziell zu machen
wir dann geringfügig dies nicht gewalt
dass das kreuz die türkische programm
das es überhaupt gibt eine plastik von
hans josef und dieser kopf hat mir
gesagt das ist meine freundin und der
fahrer hat diesen kopf gesehen hat das
ist der broadcaster neben gefällt mir
gut es jetzt in dieser kapelle aus
bruder klaus da und da gibt es noch ein
symbol und das war's also also kapellen
sie eine tolle aufgabe weil sie so
anspruchslos sind im liturgischen
programm und nichts belehrung das haben
ja sein art andacht ruhe der entspannung
wir haben außen darf die die nicht reid
wollte bänke gemacht wo man sich
hinsetzen kann ganz ohne zünder und im
zelt schauen ja und einer open kommt der
regen ein
da fühlen sie sich wohl gehen sie oft
nicht
naja da fühle ich mich nicht wohl aber
das hab ich häufig bei denen das ist
auch ein fall so oder so das kommt mir
zu ich hab dann auch keine
berührungsangst so und frei wird er noch
leute dabei sind und ich denke ich danke
ihnen sehr herzlich für das gespräch
nächste woche geht es in wahrheit
geheimnis und verschwörung mein kollege
ich boss hat spricht mit zwei experten
über verschwörungstheorien und fragt
warum sie für viele menschen so
anziehend sind gerade heute und jetzt
gleich zeigt die sternstunde kunst einen
film über junge künstlerinnen und
künstler in der schweiz wie arbeiten sie
wie leben sie wir haben fünf von ihnen
werden fünf jahren mit der kamera
begleitet bleiben sie also dran und
einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]